so check this out this is the lenovo
ideapad you 110 and i love a look of
this computer i think this is awesome in
fact if you look at this like it's it
looks from a distance it looks just like
this beautiful red but if you get up
close to it and look at the detail in
there they call it the tendril detail
the tendril detail like flowery detail
it's beautiful what it is actually is a
Olympic torch red because the lenovo
actually designed the limit the company
that made this computer designed the
Olympic torch that's being used in the
two thousand eight games and they use
some of the same design motif on the
cover and on the back like the heating
vents actually have kind of a little
ancient Chinese detail to them so I
really like that kind of nice design
touch but what I like about is that it's
very gripping yeah I can feel it you can
right hold it and I'm not going to throw
it but seriously when you're when you're
talking about really small laptops
you're going to be carrying them around
traveling with them one of the important
things is it it's going to be in your
hand and a lot of these other laptops
like the e the sony vaio TZ are really
easy like to just drop slippery they're
slippery the only thing though is that
it doesn't have an optical drive if you
want to play CDs or DVDs you got to plug
this little guy in and then you've got
to add the cable to connect it and then
of course you need the power brick which
is small but not non-existent so by the
time you get all those things in your
bag along with the laptop here over four
pounds so let's look at the performance
well 120 gigs hard drive yeah so that's
pretty good similar to the toshiba r500
ultralight right now just two gigs
around no I think that's a little bit
underpowered especially for a machine
that's running Windows Vista all right
well yeah I mean we tested a little bit
and this session came out ok but quake
what out that's what I want to know can
it play quake it can play quake very
slow ok given the processor and the rim
I mean you're not really going to be
playing games on this this is designed
to be doing serious work on what I like
about the keyboard is for a pretty
compact pc this keyboard is actually
pretty spacious the keys are large and
you know it's easy to hit even if you've
got kind of fat fingers yeah but there's
they have sort of a cheap plastic you
feel to them um you can sort of see they
pick up fingerprints and when you type
on them there's kind of like it doesn't
feel solid this is none like this is not
the kind of keyboard that lenovo has
made its name with the other thing
that's different about this check this
out what's missing here it's a Lenovo
and yet there's no little eraser mouse
they've done with the completely
trackpad here so there is a webcam built
into this um which i think is cool and
it enables a security feature right yeah
they call this the very face security
feature so instead of just remembering
your password which is really hard
sometimes you can stare at it and you
can see it will try to scan your eyes
and the outlines of your face to see if
you're the real owner which is kind of
creepy so my other big beef with this
computer it's eighteen hundred dollars
for that's a big one for the two gig
version at 50 bucks and you can get a
three gig version with three gigs of ram
but then it's not red anymore I mean
that's really the main attraction of
this computer is that it's for a
beautiful styling yeah so how does this
rate on a scale of one to ten we did our
blue wall rating it came out at seven
out of ten 700 is great so it's a great
score it's better than just recommended
its quality quality product
you